hi everyone I'm Alana on cheralathan and
I'm moving house pretty soon so I
thought that I would make a house to a
vlog because I don't know I'm gonna miss
this house I've lived it for almost half
of my life so I'm pretty sad to be
leaving so right now I'm on my bed well
this is my bedroom which I'm sure a lot
of you would have seen in my room to a
video stuff has changed since then and I
haven't cleaned it at all so this is
what it looks like outside there's a
park over there which I always really
liked and then we go out here ah this is
one of my living rooms and that's my cat
he was apparently hungry and then I'll
briefly show you this is my sister's
room she's probably not gonna want me to
go in there and then Hey look a toilet
this is my bathroom
oh hey everyone the new house the
bathrooms are like white and stuff and I
don't know something about white
bathrooms and I just really like so
that's that closet more cat were you
even doing and this is my parents
bedroom and I'm always like holy crap
this stuff I could do if I had this
bedroom it is massive I could have like
10 glass cabinets in here they're
enormous and super comfy bed that
cupboard is enormous too this is mom's
like little me copy thing where she does
makeup and stuff Hey look another
bathroom why now we go down the stairs
and this cat is totally gonna come with
me because he thinks it's Jenna so this
here is another lounge room we call this
the reading room and that's my laundry
well my cat get it and why he's being
noisy so then this is the study um there
used to be a computer there but that's
been sold and stuff and then a fast
machine we everyone always asks why I
have a fax machine like to fax things
obviously boxes oh my god this used to
be a spare bedroom but um is now not
clearly and then here is a really handy
marriage
now it here is my front yard one of the
gnomes my best friend gets me gnomes and
he steals them from people's yards and
then gives them to me and I have like
three this here is a water fountain and
cute little chat oh hi Carl
and I guess this is where we leave you
this is my street cameras not in focus
but I can't fix it and then this here is
my house from the outside and that's my
bedroom window up there and then you
come back inside oh hey look the cat's
still hungry
is that squeaking savvy out you don't
worry mm-hmm
we go this way um this is the like main
living room as opposed the TV um I think
those are my South Park DVDs so I tend
to come in here if I'm drawing or video
editing late at night or even writing
and this is where I sit just here this
is sick but this way is the kitchen
I actually really like out kitchen even
though it is a little bit old garlic to
keep the vampires away
it's actually just for cooking bench
obviously really really sexy fruit bowl
oh that's my tea I've got about that
fridge and then the pantry over here is
our dining table what we don't actually
eat here very often we most often eat in
the living room or outside right now it
has this really ugly cloth on it because
we've been putting stuff on it to be
able to pack so it doesn't normally look
covered in lemons and he's like bar
stools more stuff okay outside totally
my favorite part of this house I read
their drink Tina ether on that that seat
right there
another terracotta warrior because one's
not enough damn there's another place
where we sort of eat dinner this is
where I Sun baked and another one and
the pool
it's heated so it's pretty excellent and
then this is what the house looks like
from the back
but I guess that is it for me today
everyone I know this is probably a
really random video that no one's really
interested in but I kind of wanted to
document it just for myself like I want
to have this video do you have to look
back at it and be like oh with the house
and it's kind of heavy but um my dog
passed away in October and she was like
the best thing ever
she was totally my best friend so
there's a lot of stuff about this house
that makes me really think of my dog and
I think that leaving is gonna make me
really sad about that like she used to
sleep just there so I guess I will see
you guys next time bye